Papa Papa um [ __ ] hey what's going on
YouTube now recently I have been
bombarded with this with this request to
talk about something that happened on
YouTube I guess I should I I do owe you
that cuz I said I would talk about the
stuff you send me so here we go now
recently a youtuber who I had no idea
who he was until I saw this video wow
he's really popular but this guy Matthew
Santoro apparently came out with this
video where he's talking about how he
was abused not even just verbally abused
but physically abused by his
ex-girlfriend and I was looking at
another oh my god like Dan you putting
this out at a judo video and you guys
know about me how I feel about airing
out like personal private dirty laundry
I don't think that's a really great
platform to do it and I'm just like oh
but maybe he's trying to like raise
awareness for you know people who do get
into like domestic violence you know
violent relationships and then we found
out who his ex-girlfriend is his
ex-girlfriend apparently is another
youtuber named Nicole Harbor I was like
God Nicole Harbour sounds really
familiar
we got my kisser here today you don't
know if this is hairspray or semen she's
no [ __ ] dear fat people girl dear fat
people and you know what the shocking
thing about that was prior to be knowing
this in that small little window of time
I had to research who he was he's like a
really like clean-cut clean jokes dude
and his girlfriend is the exact opposite
of them and to be straight up I don't
even think he really can be evil have
you seen how white his teeth are that's
all got the nicest teeth I've ever seen
on earth
y'all ever see a supervillain with teeth
like that my [ __ ] got a deal
from crested [ __ ] what's up his Tila
like brand new piano keys her teeth
white too but they not as nice as his if
we're basing good and evil on teeth she
evil as [ __ ] I'm not saying she's a
[ __ ] or anything cuz I don't [ __ ]
know her personally I just you know the
video that I made was just in response
to what she said nothing nothing against
her if anything it was kind of like that
whole Kramer situation when he would say
those racist comments like oh hey
then of course Nicole is not gonna sit
there and take it she's gonna have her
own take about what happened and she's
obviously gonna defend herself if in
fact she did not physically or verbally
abuse him like I said if he's out there
trying to give people awareness about
domestic violence then I guess that's
cool but the one odd thing I do have to
ask is if you kept it private for a
whole year and why how did you
accidentally make it public now mind you
by him making it accidentally public
it's kind of odd for me because if you
guys are on YouTube he probably posted a
lot more videos about that so he would
have to have gone through the whole
thing went to the video click down go
all the way down to that arrow and say
publish like I don't know if you can do
that on accident and if you did it on
purpose you should have just owned up to
it that's just my opinion not sure if
that's true something I want to tell you
guys once again take it with a grain of
salt is that you do realize that a lot
of youtubers that you see online like
they fabricate a lot of [ __ ] me not so
much to be honest with you you could ask
any kid that met me at a college show
I'm exactly why I'm on camera that you
see in person maybe even nicer just a
little bit more quieter cuz obviously if
I see you in person I'm not gonna be
like hey what's going on guys if you
want me to give you examples like these
long personalities I'm not talking about
vlogs where people talking to the camera
I'm talking about like where they wake
up in the morning they're like what's up
whoa what's cracking everybody good my
[ __ ] you wake up like that every
morning get the [ __ ] on at it you don't
wake up like that or even these pranks
did you guys think our social
experiments and then you get played on
this and you you know you guys want to
say something like oh they're such a
good person is this really how the world
is really they're their social
experiments that are based on hiring
actors to act these situations out are
supposed to be an honest representation
of this world that's not a social
experiment you're making people think
things that aren't true but that's just
a small piece of things I'm really not
gonna get into this asking me what I
think about the whole situation honestly
I like keeping certain things private
you know YouTube is made for
entertainment and then to kind of like
connect with your fans and viewers and
stuff like that but at the same time if
you don't keep anything private to
yourself not that
saying that if he got abused he should
just never tell anybody it's a good
thing you do tell people just to get it
off your chest and for you to start your
therapy and the healing process but is
it to that point now where youtubers are
going to use their fan base to hate
other people to make them and hate
somebody else and to use that as a
catalyst and an argument in a fight
between I don't understand like that's
so free that's so wrong is I don't get I
don't know Matthew I don't know you I've
never met you when you seem like a nice
ass dude I hope and I pray to God you
didn't get your ass beat by that girl
and if you did I'm sorry that you went
through that I don't know about being
abused by somebody I'm with if a girl
came at me with a fist you best believe
I'm [ __ ] farting in my hand cupping
and throwing you right in the mouth
that's right that's some poison warfare
right now I wish the crazy [ __ ] would
hit me you wouldn't even know I won't
hit you I sure as [ __ ] spit you either
blind you like a venomous Python so I
have a question out there for the
viewers do you guys think youtubers
should air out all their personal
business out for the public to see or
and number two do you think that she
actually did abuse him or three do you
think Matthew Santoro is acting or
number four do you just not give a [ __ ]
Matthew man are those who's watching you
cry what's hard dude I hope you're not
going through some [ __ ] like that and I
hope you don't ever have to go to that
[ __ ] again Nicole if you beat his ass
Dan you a scary woman you don't even
look that strong
you must good you what you live what you
power lift or something got down but
yeah people I just wonder what do you
guys think